this is the thing this is a blind spot
of a lot of people who are fortunate
enough to have been born and grow up in
a country like the USA or the UK
especially if they haven't travelled
mm-hmm a lot is that you people do not
understand just how good they have it I
think we live in a time where for a lot
of various reasons people are losing
their sense of humor in a way and with
me you know sometimes someone will hear
me chuckle or laugh at this oh you
shouldn't laugh at that that's not funny
I don't like no it is funny it is funny
if you have a golden Trump Tower on
Greenland and he's saying look don't
worry I'm not gonna do this to Greenland
you know that's fine yeah that's just a
sense of humor and even if you do find
that even if someone does find some of
the whole process or situation
frustrating or annoying or what I mean
what better way to deal with something
than just be able to laugh at it you
know when the time comes to go and vote
vote for whoever you think is the right
person if you like Trump go vote for
Trump if you don't like Trump go vote
for whoever you think is going to do a
better job if he's as terrible as you
can see you're saying he is it shouldn't
be that hard to find somebody who you
think will do a better job but
ultimately your success or your failure
is not gonna have anything to do with
the government unless you get some sort
of huge tyrannical regime that's really
really cracking down on people's
freedoms and their ability to do things
whether your life is great or your life
sucks
normally it's not gonna have anything to
do with the government or politics let
alone any individual politician so if
you're somebody who for the past
two-and-a-half years has been
complaining about Oh Trump has ruined
the US or Trump has ruin my life or
whatever you know I had some people who
speak in my language man yeah finish
that thought bring that because I think
that's it right there you're saying this
guy and this government is evil it's not
about replace it's not about just
getting your guy in and in a more
powerful government it's about perhaps
taking a little bit of that power back
maybe that's the easier way to do a bad
way to do it I mean everyone is you're
gonna succeed you're gonna fail largely
off of your own terms
this is the thing this is a blind spot
of a lot of people who are fortunate
enough to have been born and grow up in
a country like the USA or the UK
especially if they haven't travelled
mm-hmm a lot is that you people do not
understand just how good they have it
even someone who by American standards
is not up up in the top on a global
level you're still people want to talk
about the one percent you're still I
think I think to be in the one percent I
was I looked this up I think if you earn
over $31,000 a year then in terms of
income you are in the global the global
we're saying here in this global 1% with
an income of $31,000 and then once you
factor in opportunity and healthcare and
life expectancy and just opportunity I
mean most people in the world would bite
your hand off to be living in a council
estate in the UK or in a hood in the US
and this I'm still trying to come here
right yeah talking people in absolutely
so this isn't saying that there are no
problems in these individual countries
in certain cities of course there are
but I just think that in 2019 what a lot
of people are just missing is a sense of
gratitude gratitude and perspective I
think are the two things that a lot of
people are missing when you're seeing
everybody just angry and shouting and
complaining and saying this is horrible
and this is terrible and I'm like what
are you comparing things to what what do
you think that says about the human
condition maybe or the way the internet
the way we can't really understand the
way the Internet is changing us because
obviously the Internet has done
incredible things and connected us and
you know we met through Twitter yeah
evil Twitter right so like there's all
of this incredible stuff people are
watching this on the internet but that's
all spectacular and amazing and
mind-blowing from only 20 years ago and
yet on the other hand then it keeps
people in this odd paralysis or this
this state of lack of gratitude or lack
of understanding how good it is in in a
lot of these places in the yes well I
think we used to think that the problem
was lack of access to information and I
think that the internet has proven that
that's not that's not but yeah I just
think it's a
I think it's well I think it's actually
a lot of things I think it's a lot of
things I think it's a lack of
understanding of history and knowing how
good stuff is in 2019 compared to prior
decades I mean it wasn't so long ago
that we did really live in you know
there were virulent amounts of racism
and homophobia and sexism and bigotry
and you stuff enshrined in law which
says okay this group can do that this
group cannot do that this people can do
that and and in the West that has
basically been obliterated yeah and
that's
yeah and that's and that's incredible I
mean if you think of the thousand a
thousand several thousand year
perspective you know two hundred years
ago
less than two hundred years ago people
could own slaves by that existed four
thousand an institution existed for
thousands of years that on a grand
scheme of things you know and you look
at poverty levels and what people have
access to and things like that I mean a
poor person now or you know relatively
poor lives better than royalty not so
long ago has a higher life expectancy
has better health care things like that
and I think part of it is part of the
lack of gratitude is people not
understanding that history and then also
not people not having a good global
perspective of how billions of people
around the world actually live and what
they're going through and what they deal
with I mean I always feel really
grateful for example when I you know
when I do go back to Nigeria and I'm
going through certain parts of the
country or you're in certain areas or
certain villages and whatever and you're
just seeing how people are living and
how millions and hundreds of millions of
people billions of people are living and
whatnot and you can't go there as
someone who lives in in the UK or lives
in the US and is you know doing
relatively well you can't go there and
not just have a perspective shift of
being like wow like I need to stop I
need to stop complaining about
everything because there are a lot of
people here almost everybody here would
very gladly swap over with me so
whatever I think is going wrong in the
UK or whatever I think is silly or
whatever
yeah good to talk about it but all
timidly stuff works really well so
basically the people on the right should
be funding they should be crowdfunding
trips really to get like the the truly
privileged lefties of America to to go
to some of these places and realize just
for I mean it wouldn't take that long
see just to see the difference of how
good it is
yeah it's good idea and then you know so
I think it's that I do also think a
factor is um the I think lots of the
ideologies that we're talking about now
the goal is to create problems where
they don't exist really so you'll have
you'll now have people trying to find
you know people are like looking at
every nook and cranny for they're trying
to find the hidden racism we're trying
to find the hidden sexes money it's like
if you have to go looking for it and
start inventing new concepts to even
find it so for example you'll hear
people say things like America or the UK
oh it's it's just as racist as it ever
was but it's just different now
and I'm like sure that's don't think
that's a stupid statement that's a
stupid statement like no no one is
saying that these things completely 100%
do not exist in anybody's heart or brain
yeah of course they do then get people
who are bigoted but in terms of the
society as a whole or the the average
person I mean I don't know how anyone in
their right mind could say that the u.s.
is a more racist now than it was 100
years ago or 50 years ago for 30 years
ago oh it's always more it's more
homophobic I mean you didn't get hate
crammed as you were walking here in LA
no no I've been ok there on streets I
think that's it I had a few people
saying that I should be careful of
visiting the US now that Trump is
president I mean that was just like you
really think that it's like stop
watching whatever watching because
though and it's just not it's not true
it's it'll be fine like um you know or
it's the people saying yeah you know if
you're a black guy and you're going to
the states and you know gotta be careful
like you know don't don't interact with
the cops or them
I'm kind of like man there's a Starbucks
about a mile away from you want to go
over there and see what happens you know
it's yeah it's it's just it's strange it
is strange but yeah I think lack of
perspective lack of gratitude whatever
whatever sources those things stem from
those are really what poison people's
brains and I think it's I think it's a
shame because I think that's what's
really disempowering the people as well
I'm very much big on you know personal
responsibility and I do believe that if
you live in a country with great
opportunity everyone starts at a
different level certainly some people
have advantages and disadvantages of all
sorts so your starting point is not this
is not determined by you right the the
universe god whatever the situation is
that gives you your your starting point
you don't choose your parents you don't
choose your country of birth your city
your birth socioeconomic status anything
like that and that's good to understand
but over the course of an entire
lifetime over the course of many decades
I do think that where you end up is for
the most part mmm-hmm up to you
it's not up to the system it's not up to
the government it's not up to any
politician or party you are the person
and how sad it would be if it was right
yeah yeah it is sad so I think most
people sort of inherently know this too
but they still are continually looking
for that thing above them that person or
oh if only we can get this guy into
office then all of our problems will be
that that person doesn't exist that
policy doesn't exist that party doesn't
exist you can vote for ones that you
think more aligned with your your views
and your policies and things like that
but there's nothing that's gonna happen
that's gonna fundamentally turn you from
a someone who's failing someone who's
super successful I mean that's that's
really a mindset shift that's something
that you've got to take on yourself if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell